sí
bienvenidos al debate de france 24 soy
santiago lópez gonzález rafael correa-
político ecuatoriano ex presidente de
ese país suramericano por 10 años
actualmente radicado en bélgica en el
norte de europa anunció sorpresivamente
para muchos también esperado para otros
sectores ecuatorianos que volvería a la
escena política de su país para
continuar con su proyecto de la
revolución ciudadana ha dicho que
regresa no porque tenga deseos de
regresar y continuar en la escena
política de su país sino porque se lo
han pedido pongámonos en contexto
rafael correa- gobernó ecuador por una
décadas ya lo decía con su partido
alianza país su primer período fue de
2007 al 2009 si bien su primer mandato
debía terminar en el 2011 hubo un
llamado a elecciones anticipadas y una
reforma a la carta magna de ese país y
por eso se tuvo que presentar nuevamente
a las elecciones presidenciales pese a
haber gobernado solamente por dos años
correa volvió a presentarse en estos
comicios donde resultó ganador este
segundo período presidencial fue del año
2009 al 2013
y una tercera participación en comicios
o populares lo llevó a la reelección
presidencial para un tercer periodo
desde el año 2013 al 2017
correa quien vivía ahora en europa
anunció recientemente que volvería
entonces a la escena política de ecuador
pero desde otro cargo no como presidente
el ex mandatario aspira al cargo de
vicepresidente para estos comicios que
serán realizados en febrero del 2000 21
siendo fórmula de andrés araus quien fue
parte de su gabinete durante su gobierno
la dupla araus correa intentará llegar
al poder con una coalición llamada
coalición unión por la esperanza que
cuenta también con el apoyo de centro
democrático y de fuerza compromiso
social
pero rafael correa no tiene fácil ese
posible retorno a la política
ecuatoriana hoy en día fuertemente
polarizado ese país y con divisiones
también al interior de su propio partido
sobre correa pesa una sentencia de ocho
años de prisión por delito de cohecho
una sentencia que recibió en ausencia
por encontrarse como ya lo decíamos en
bélgica desde el año 2017 la defensa de
correa hizo uso de un recurso de
casación su último recurso legal para
revertir esta sentencia se espera que
las autoridades legales ecuatorianas
entonces den alguna respuesta en los
próximos días a este recurso dicha
respuesta definirá el futuro del regreso
o no de correa a ecuador para participar
en los comicios presidenciales del 2021
para analizar entonces este tema hemos
invitado a maría paz services ella es
decana de la facultad de ciencias
sociales y jurídicas de la wilczek y nos
atiende desde la ciudad de quito la
capital ecuatoriana también está con
nosotros el señor pabel muñoz él es
asambleístas de la bancada revolución
ciudadana también se encuentra en la
ciudad de quito y el señor homero
castanier el ex asambleísta del
movimiento creando oportunidades creo
que se une a esta conversación desde la
ciudad de azogues sus opiniones también
son muy importantes para nosotros por
favor dejen todos sus comentarios y sus
preguntas en france 24 y arroba sant y
luego deje los comentarios con el
numeral el debate efe 24 pues tenemos a
los invitados y tenemos el tema voy a
comenzar entonces con varias en las
ciudades de quito preguntándole
la gran pregunta que se están haciendo
los ecuatorianos y también los
latinoamericanos el ex presidente correa
si puede regresar a ecuador para
participar en estos comicios para hacer
aspirar a la vicepresidencia de su país
buenas noches muchísimas gracias por la
invitación y a quienes los escuchan
bueno la pregunta que me plantea es la
gran pregunta del millón lo cierto de
poder regresar él puede regresar pero lo
primero que tendría que hacer el ex
presidente correa es dar cara a los
procesos judiciales que están abiertos
uno con sentencia en casación y otro que
justamente no se lo puede sentenciar
porque no está aquí en el país y no se
le puede no se puede dictar la sentencia
en su ausencia que es el caso por el por
el secuestro del señor baltar con lo
cual de poder volver él puede volver
ahora que pueda volver y ex y poder
evitar los procesos judiciales y
saltarse para ir directo a una campaña
electoral eso yo lo veo más complicado
lo ve complicada la opinión de maría
para service pabel muñoz su opinión
sobre este tema puede o no el presidente
el ex presidente correa regresar a su
país para aspirar otra vez a un cargo de
elección popular
santiago buenas noches a quienes nos ven
en américa latina y el mundo lo propio
el expresidente correa puede desde
nuestro punto de vista como militantes
del proceso de la revolución ciudadana
queremos que venga a afrontar el proceso
electoral siendo candidato a
vicepresidente como bien lo decían las
notas introductorias ahora yo cometería
un error santiago si no permito que por
fuera del ecuador la gente vea el bosque
y no se entretenga en los árboles cuando
digo esto es que en el ecuador está
pasando estrategias políticas que ya las
hemos vivido en otras latitudes de otros
países de américa latina veamos el caso
de bolivia la proscripción de
participación política lula veamos lo
que se quiso hacer en argentina con
cristina fernández de kirchner veamos lo
que se hizo en su momento con nuevo
morales y ahora con su candidato
presidencial
luís arce y es exactamente lo mismo de
copia y pega lo que está pasando en el
ecuador cierra diciéndole que eso que
significa que tenemos desde nuestro
punto de vista un proceso de persecución
que opera en cuatro aristas la
administrativa la judicial la
comunicacional y es una novedad que
ahora mismo se vive en bolivia y en
ecuador
héctor al querer impedir la
participación electoral de rafael correa
como persona o de su tienda política
fuerza compromiso social y el señor
homero castanier su opinión puede el ex
presidente correa participar nuevamente
en un cargo de elección popular
bueno la noche es un saludo y
definitivamente no definitivamente no
recordemos que en el año 2018 una
consulta popular un referéndum aquí en
el ecuador en donde la mayoría del
electorado le dijo no a la reelección
indefinida a los cargos de elección
popular incluyendo al presidente y al
vicepresidente de la república
al no haber esa posibilidad quien ejerce
la vicepresidencia tiene los mismos
requisitos y las mismas inhabilidades
que el presidente se fue el espíritu de
esa norma y no puede buscarse esa
argucia legal de que ahora me
candidatizó para vicepresidente pudiendo
renunciar el presidente y ejercer por
tercera vez un mandato cuando aquí se
permite la reelección por una sola vez y
el segundo tema el tema de la situación
de que necesita el presentarse
presencialmente para su inscripción
necesita el está con procesos legales
está con una sentencia y aquí lo claro
es imagínense el corto de la democracia
no permite ser candidatos por ejemplo a
quienes deben pensiones alimenticias no
se diga en estos casos en donde quieren
buscar estos mecanismos
matizar se ejerce y que han sido de
nombre
bueno más adelante retomamos la conexión
con el señor homero castanier para
conocer su opinión sobre este tema vamos
a arreglar el problema técnico que
tenemos con su conexión y continuamos
preguntándole lo que estábamos
conversando con él mientras tanto maría
paz en la ciudad de quito a ver aquí hay
dos puntos de vista de acuerdo a la
opinión de nuestros invitados y también
lo que usted nos ha dicho se habla por
un lado de una persecución y también por
otro lado de una intención de pronto del
expresidente correa de intentar pasarse
por encima algunas leyes porque él ya
fue reelecto ya hizo parte del gobierno
de ese país ya hizo uso digámoslo así de
todas sus posibilidades para poder
ejercer un cargo de elección popular
cuál es su análisis entonces al respecto
en primer lugar saludo a mis compañeros
de panel que eso se me pasó al inicio
muy buenas noches es un gusto poder
compartir este espacio con ustedes
también pero como ellos mismo empezaron
diciendo lo de manera muy muy frontal en
el primer caso el señor muñoz él dice
nosotros queremos que vuelva por tu
puedes querer que vuelva desde la
militancia no es cierto pero aquí
tenemos dos niveles nuevamente que es el
político y es de legal a nivel legal
como yo indicaba
hay dos temas que se tienen que atender
y es que hay dos juicios en curso aquí
yo no voy a decir cuál es lo que yo
quiero porque lo que queremos es estar
el nivel político no cierto pero aquí
hay dos hechos y los hechos dos pues
discutir es que hay dos sentencias
después el cuento este de que de que
todo político es perseguido político
bueno esto suele pasar esto también
estamos acostumbrados bien señalaba el
caso de américa latina estamos muy
acostumbrados o sea yo creo que desde el
punto de vista como ciudadana desde el
lugar donde estoy yo como ciudadana como
docente universitaria quizás lo que a
nosotros más nos duele es que no vamos a
normalizar que quienes han pasado por
puestos de toma de decisión en el estado
ecuatoriano terminan siempre sindicados
no esto es algo eso es una pena y claro
obviamente la salida cuando hay actos
corrupción cuando hay ilícitos como es
el hecho del secuestro donde donde se
fue fue encontrado culpable no se pudo
sentenciar le porque no se encuentra
aquí en el país es antes de pensar en
una candidatura yo entendería que
legalmente lo primero tiene que hacer es
presentarse ante las autoridades a las
cortes no cierto pero claro siempre es
bien esta cosa de es que está politizado
que quieren evitar es lo que denominamos
no sé si en colombia también se dice
pero en el ecuador se dice leguleyada no
es cierto que esta manera de interpretar
la ley y me gustó lo que decía el
asambleísta castañeda que hablaba del
espíritu de la ley yo creo que es algo
fundamental desde ese temor de quedarnos
siempre en la letra chiquita en el punto
y como cuando hay un espíritu y lo que
lo que buscaba el legislador cuando
cuando se plantearon estos requisitos es
justamente que las personas que tienen
algo pendiente con la ley no pueden
estar capacitados para contiendas
políticas ponía el ejemplo si algo como
las pensiones alimenticias que desde
luego es relevante que inhabilita como
podría no inhabilitarse el hecho de
haber estado vinculado en un caso de
secuestro de cuando ejercía impuestos de
primera
y no haberse presentado entonces ya por
ahí y sin mencionar el caso sobornos que
efectivamente se encuentre en casación
el segundo nivel es el político y el
político creo que tenemos que volver a
lo mismo no estamos pensando que tenemos
un país devastado económicamente
devastado con instituciones devastadas y
estamos aquí a última hora siempre
tratando de ver en qué lugar en qué
puesto de la papeleta se ubica cada
quien para que dada la ley yo estoy
convencida que los ecuatorianos y
ecuatorianos nos merecemos candidatos y
candidatas que primero den la cara a las
instituciones del estado y después
piensen en campañas si el primero el
nivel político de los candidatos el
papel muñoz también hay en la ciudad de
quito le pregunto por qué correa debería
regresar que le falta que le quedó
pendiente después de estos años de
gobierno porque él dice que no regresa
por gusto propio sino porque le han
pedido que regrese es también parte de
estos discursos que dan los diferentes
mandatarios y ex mandatarios de la
región de américa latina que tratan de
regresar aquí un poco como ídolos y como
salvadores del caos
y la respuesta siempre es como el caos o
yo y quien estaría faltando entonces a
correa que la obligaría a tener que
regresar a ecuador a cumplir su proyecto
de la revolución ciudadana
primero también un saludo para maría paz
y un saludo para mí evidentemente
santiago lo voy a contradecir le voy a
contradecir porque un elemento a la nota
y otro elemento a su opinión a la nota
señalaba como si rafael correa hubiera
dejado el país queriendo no darle cara a
los procesos judiciales esto no es así
rafael correa tiene una esposa que es
belga sus hijos tienen doble
nacionalidad y él anunció desde hace
mucho tiempo que terminada su tercera
presidencia dejaría el ecuador para
replegarse con su familia esta lógica
entre caos y los líderes que lograron
que digamos que el pueblo se gobierne a
sí mismo o que el estado tomara
decisiones para las grandes mayorías eso
sí creo que es lo que está en debate y
el ecuador en estos tres años y medio de
gobierno que se que se suponía tenía que
si usted quiere consolidar bajo la
lógica de políticas de estado los logros
de la revolución ciudadana ha hecho del
país un desastre bien lo decía maría paz
en este momento vamos a hacer el país
seguramente en segundo lugar que mayor
decrecimiento tengamos las cifras no sé
si no se definen de lo que dicen las
supuestas cifras oficiales respecto a
kobe 19 tenemos 30 mil muertes
exceso en el ecuador nos convertimos en
el país de los primeros países en
américa latina' en no haber atendido la
hacia la luz fíjense que hoy se
preocupan por el gasto de 42 millones de
dólares en el proceso electoral pero
pagaron en la peor época de la pandemia
mil 909 millones de dólares a los
tenedores y ustedes habrían este
programa con una nota del banco mundial
diciendo que vamos a tener 100 mil
personas en pobreza y que el banco
mundial sugiere la prórroga e incluso el
perdón de algunas deudas para américa
latina cierro santiago de manera muy
breve
desmenuzando los tres argumentos que se
han puesto sobre la mesa
homero castanier dice la reelección y es
cierto que no se puede haber una más de
una reelección para un carro pero el
cargo de vicepresidente es otro por lo
tanto creo que ese elemento no cabe y
maría paz hacía referencia a los
procesos legales yo quisiera que ella
tuviera razón pero lo cierto es que como
se maneja la justicia esto está en
entredicho hay dos principios que no
deberían prestarse presunción de
inocencia y debido proceso y mientras no
se dé la sentencia de casación correa no
tiene sentencia ejecutoriada por lo
tanto incluso en el marco legal él puede
presentarse
importante ese punto que usted toca para
velas y en la ciudad de quito - su
opinión al respecto sobre lo que ha
dicho para ver
bueno les decía el tema de se me corto
el tema de que no podría ser candidato
porque las mismas inhabilidades y
prohibiciones para el presidente son las
del vicepresidente eso dicen 149 de la
constitución y no podría reelegirse y
también decía cómo es esto de que esta
cucharada de exmandatarios en donde está
la señora fernández de argentina
entonces está morales en bolivia en
donde está lula en en brasil todos
pertenecientes a una misma corriente
ideológica buscaban participar a la
brava reformar la constitución quedarse
23 veces quedarse eternamente como un
mecanismo de buscar inmunidad a los
cometimiento de actos de corrupción
debería aplicarse a rajatabla esta
imposibilidad de que vuelvan a
participar imagínense que aquí el código
de la democracia permite en su artículo
108 que cuando se inscriben de
candidatos se suspenden los procesos
legales
si ganan los candidatos los ganadores
gozan de fuero de corte eso es lo que
están buscando este es el tema muy fácil
hubiera sido evitar esta serie policiaca
que estamos viviendo en actos de
corrupción y mal llamada de persecución
política porque no es uno no es rafael
correa está para el correa es jorge
glass es el primo de rafael correa pedro
delgado es el tío de rafael correa desde
el ministro ex ministro solís carlos
pareja yannuzzelli alexis mera
vinicio alvarado fernando alvarado raúl
patiño asambleístas jugados carlos ochoa
es decir más de una veintena de ex
funcionarios del ex gobierno de correa
que están huidos del país
entonces de la transparencia hubiera
permitido que se eviten ya digo esta
imposibilidad de ser candidatos y de
presentarse como una política o una
opción de ser
pavel otra de las preguntas del millón
en este caso porque es que todos los
escenarios generan incógnita en este
caso del ex presidente correa porque
como ya lo decíamos es muy de la minucia
de la legislación ecuatoriana y otra de
las preguntas que surge y que queda
sobre la mesa es si esta sentencia está
ejecutoriada o no es la pregunta que se
le está haciendo a este juez de juez de
casación y la gran respuesta que está
esperando ecuador y la comunidad
internacional desde su punto de vista
esta sentencia está ejecutoriada o no
primero permítanme decir dos cosas así
simples nada más mire lo que se dice en
el caso ecuatoriano un cierto se dice
dos desde mi punto de vista de
argumentos ridículos correa utilizó o
malversó setenta mil millones de dólares
de la economía ecuatoriana no es cierto
pero la sentencia que le ponen de ocho
años de prisión es por un supuesto una
supuesta participación inmediata donde
lo hubiera ejercido influjo psíquico ya
te hace un cuento esté más o menos cuál
es la lógica de los argumentos sin ser
abogado le digo que entonces de esa
sentencia que le acusa a él de haber
tenido influjo psíquico puede ser que
digamos apelada en una primera instancia
y va al segundo momento del juicio se
han ratificado en esa instancia y se
apela por tercera ocasión seguramente
maría paz podrá darnos más luces de esto
y entra en la etapa de casación el día
de ayer
juristas serios de este país aunque
absolutamente enemigo si usted quiere
políticos del ex presidente rafael
correa decían lo que lo que sucedió el
día de ayer en la justicia ecuatoriana
fue una ridiculez se atrevieron a decir
que la casación era un proceso aparte y
por lo tanto estaba en firme la
sentencia de correa cuando
o que la gente de derecho sensata eso sí
reconocerá que mientras no se dé la
casación esa sentencia no estará
ejecutoria pero dice maría paz
a ver efectivamente el recurso de
casación es un recurso extraordinario
donde no se revisan los hechos sino el
derecho pero definitivamente queda
suspendida la sentencia mientras se da
respuesta ese recurso yo creo que sobre
eso no hay discusión pero con eso
también quiero dejar claro que vuelvo al
tema de la leguleyada y le digo como
abogada pero sobre todo como docente
universitario que lo que hizo yo yo
tengo la inmensa responsabilidad de
participar en la formación de abogados y
abogadas desde hace muchísimos años y
ahora tengo el orgullo de dirigir una
facultad la facultad de derecho de la
universidad internacional sek y yo le
digo que tenemos que parar con esta
manía que nos que debilita tanto la
estructura de derecho democrática de
quedarnos en la letra chiquita de la ley
y con esto me insinuó que no se respete
la ley por eso soy enfática al decir que
efectivamente la casación suspende en
los efectos de la sentencia pero vamos a
ver dónde está la ética de servicio de
quien aspira a gobernar una vez más el
estado ecuatoriano
yo me pregunto más bien si es que como
ciudadanos y ciudadanas
al margen de si faltan tres días o cinco
para que exista respuesta y alcance
inscribirse corriendo
a medianoche como decimos aquí en el
ecuador entre gallos y medianoches
en el oscurito se alcanza se juega con
los tiempos con los plazos vivimos de
eso tenemos una triste historia
democrática en el ecuador de apelar a
esa estructura y seguramente durante los
10 lamentables años de gobierno del
señor del ex presidente correa que está
intentando volver al poder esto fue lo
que se institucionalizó pero eso no
implica que vamos a asumir que esa es la
lógica de un estado si la sentencia no
esté ejecutoriada pero no se olviden que
tenemos otra sentencia otra sentencia
que no se ha podido dictar pero que ya
ha fallado culpable por el tribunal
en contra del expresidente porque por un
caso de secuestro
yo me pregunto se le está acusando de
corrupción de la trama de corrupción más
grande de américa latina si es que
realmente es inocente yo defiendo el
principio de inocencia si realmente es
inocente antes de buscar salvar el
pellejo salvar el puesto a través de una
candidatura más no sería más ético más
sensato no sería mayor vocación de
servicio
el primero venir y dar la cara entonces
yo creo que la discusión de quedarnos en
la letra
de acuerdo insisto en que es la
respuesta respecto a la casación pero yo
entendería que quien aspira a gobernar
el país una vez más debería mínimamente
tener la ética que los ecuatorianos y
ecuatorianos nos merecemos que es venir
a dar la cara para los ciudadanos ese
sería el derecho de las cosas que
primero aclare su situación pero bueno
ya sabemos cómo se maneja la política en
américa latina' homero su opinión
definitivamente el peor mensaje que se
le puede dar a una sociedad es el
mensaje de impunidad
es decir cometo el ilícito cometido
actos delictivos
me enriquezco ilícitamente hago crecer
mi patrimonio
y justificada y aquí no ha pasado nada
aclarando un poco lo que decía para ver
la el juicio que se le está siguiendo a
correr es un juicio en donde pedían
coimas sobornos a empresas privadas para
financiar campañas electorales a cambio
de contratos en el estado contratos en
el ministerio de obras públicas
contratos en diferentes ministerios y me
olvidaba también la ex ministra maría de
los ángeles duarte también ungida
por estos temas entonces no es cualquier
cosa y que le vamos a dar el mensaje de
impunidad no hay problema venga nomás
candidato y cc un reo de la justicia que
se legitime una candidatura que se
suspendan las medidas cautelares que
recorre el país pidiendo el voto y que
después
si es que llegara goce de fuero de corte
estos son los mensajes que estamos dando
definitivamente si queremos cortar la
corrupción se tiene que cortar de raíz y
se tiene que hacer caso a la normativa
de rajatabla en este caso en una
reglamentación de que se dé que venga el
aceptar su candidatura de manera
personal y si bien debería ser detenido
para ver otra de las preguntas que queda
aquí que surge es si se puede creer en
la institucionalidad la justicia
ecuatoriana está bajo mucha presión con
este caso el mismo ex presidente correa
en una entrevista que yo personalmente
le dice acá en france 24 cuando fue
emitida la sentencia de estos 8 años
criticó abiertamente la
institucionalidad ecuatoriana criticó a
la justicia dijo que todo estaba
orquestado en su contra que no creía en
la institucionalidad ahora entonces en
este escenario como creer en la
respuesta que pueda dar este juez de
casación y en el proceso de suscripción
para esta candidatura si él mismo ha
dudado de la institucionalidad
ecuatoriana
claramente no se puede crear en la
institucionalidad ecuatoriana y usted
que es un periodista serio seguido de
américa latina' le revis le pido que
revise los datos de encuestas de
percepción la asamblea nacional el poder
legislativo del ecuador tiene 3 % de
aprobación y sabe quién les sigue en
mala calificación los jueces del estado
ecuatoriano por lo tanto usted decía en
américa latina ya sabemos cómo funciona
la política fuera bueno si sólo
supiéramos de eso santiago el problema
es que sabemos cómo funciona también la
justicia y aquí claramente tenemos de
eso permítanme dejar contestar las tres
cosas que quedan en el tapete
enriquecimiento y justificado y en
aumento de patrimonio donde está la
prueba de eso respecto al patrimonio de
rafael correa delgado cuando se habla de
este caso sobornos de supuestos sobornos
de empresas privadas sabe cuál fue la
prueba madre de santiago fue un cuaderno
de una de la actora premiada y sabe cómo
se construyó ese cuaderno tres años
después de lo que relataba escrito a
tiempo presente y la fecha de
publicación de ese cuaderno era
posterior a lo que decía es a esa
persona es a esa de la toda la premiada
que había
digamos descrito por lo tanto santiago
lo que necesitamos aquí yo voy a
coincidir con área paz pero insisto
quisiera que en su argumentación del
deber ser tuviera ella razón el problema
es que tenemos una distancia abismal en
la justicia ecuatoriana entre el deber
ser y el ser cuando tenemos estas
pruebas madres cuando tenemos de esas
delatoras premiadas cuando ella decía
incluso el proceso de corrupción más
grande en américa latina debemos ser un
concurso porque lo mismo dice en
argentina brasil en bolivia todos han
tenido el proceso de corrupción más
grande de américa latina entonces cuando
los casos se repiten con tantas
características similares santiago me
pregunto no será que debemos reflexionar
más críticamente esto
maria paz su opinión se puede creer en
la institucionalidad ecuatoriana y si le
quiere responder a papeleo mero adelante
bueno pues yo creo que sí coincido en
que lo mismo se dice en argentina y es
que son primos hermanos no eso derecho
igual detrás de esto y son salvadores de
la patria que llegan con el discurso de
reconstrucción de salvar de igualdad en
contra de larga noche neoliberal que el
caso ecuatoriano no fue ni tan larga ni
tan neoliberal tampoco y toda esta gente
clase trabajadora con un discurso súper
muy apegado a la emotividad y a las
masas salieron millonarios y casi todos
escapados entonces ahí sí soy enfático
si yo no voy a perder el tiempo porque
creo que que tampoco hala a quienes nos
escuchan les importa mucho tuvimos de
encima en la nota si fue hay ciertos
derechos que en una democracia tan débil
como la ecuatoriana que sufre de cáncer
terminal desde siempre vivió la época
más gris y más oscura que se puede
hablar cuando teníamos movimientos
sociales apresados cuando teníamos
periodistas presos acosados pegados
perseguidos cuando teníamos una agencia
de inteligencia persiguiendo individuos
con todavía tenemos algo que se
incorporó en la en la sociedad
ecuatoriana el ecuador no volvió a ser
el mismo
volvió y eso es algo que tenemos que
reconocer porque es un ecuador donde
nosotros tenemos centros de trolls
persiguiendo por la opinión eso es algo
que no pasaba y eso también tenemos que
reconocer que a eso nos abocamos
entonces yo creo que ante eso quedarnos
en la discusión chiquita es que no va yo
creo que es momento en que veamos las
cosas macro y desde la ciudadanía
tenemos que asumir ese debate entonces
claro se refundará una vez más la nación
como se ha refundado tantas veces yo
venir a defender la institucionalidad
ecuatoriana me encantaría me encantaría
pero no es así y por eso trabajamos
todos los días sin embargo hay ciertos
procesos que han guardado unos niveles
de transparencia y que nosotros tenemos
que exigir pero tenemos que exigir en
derecho nosotros tenemos un estado
agónico de la catastrófica que era
nuestra institucionalidad como te
recuperás de una trama ya yo sostengo lo
que nosotros tenemos en el ecuador son
carteles de la política y vemos que
están indie que están metidos a nivel de
las penitenciarías a todos los niveles
una trama de corrupción que tú no puedes
terminar ni poner fin en un gobierno ni
en dos ni en tres entonces a ellos
invito a que la sociedad ecuatoriana
participemos activamente exigiendo
transparencia y me parece
una ofensa con nuestra integridad que
una persona que huya la justicia y que
que venga a pretender una vez más salvar
el ecuador y me imagino que refundar a
todo otra vez pues como en la asamblea
del famoso congreso de los manteles
entonces yo creo que ahí está claro cuál
desde la postura de lo que nos merecemos
como ciudadanía o mero papel maria paz
me quedan pocos minutos del programa
quiero que hagamos la conclusión que nos
digan si lo que ustedes creen que va a
suceder en este complejo escenario
político que tiene ecuador además que se
suma también una polarización
impresionante que creen ustedes que va a
pasar y comienzo por homero
veremos a correr como candidato
yo pienso que no va a ser candidato no
tiene la capacidad legal la capacidad de
la capacidad moral para ser candidato
y no puede ser inscrito y si es que
logra inscribirse yo pienso que va a ser
impugnado y no va a estar en la papeleta
definitivamente yo pienso que no es solo
cuaderno la prueba para abel del tema
del tema coimas y sobornos son
declaraciones son situaciones que salían
desde la propia presidencia de la
republica premiado hacia sus ministros
realicen nos preguntamos los
ecuatorianos si alguien que le pagamos
todos un sueldo para administrar y
controlar no lo hizo dos razones o era
cómplice o era inepto para hacer el
cargo
para ver su conclusión
maría paz decía que en la política hay
sectores que funcionan como carteles
seguramente sí tiene razón así como la
academia hay políticos disfrazados de
académicos de eso también pasa fíjese lo
interesante de este señalamiento de
maría paz dice en argentina y en ecuador
primos de hermanos y estaba presente
odebrecht pero sabe que en el ecuador
les sacaron del proceso judicial a
odebrecht que va a pasar santiago vamos
a ganar las elecciones del 2021 si
asumimos que maría paz y digamos número
castaña tienen la razón cual el miedo de
que se presente si hemos hecho todo mal
vamos a perder abrumadoramente las
elecciones esta no es la realidad de
entrada tenemos cerca de 30 por ciento
de intención de voto y ese es el pánico
no es cierto que se les nota en
cualquier intervención a los opositores
de nuestro gobierno lo que va a pasar en
el febrero de 2021 santiago se lo firma
ahora es que vamos a ganar estas
elecciones si es que todo hay que
decirlo- papel
rafael correa pese a estar fuera de
ecuador desde hace muchos años y detener
estos procesos en su contra sigue siendo
muy popular entre muchos sectores de la
sociedad ecuatoriana maría para su
conclusión para el cierre
no sé lo que va a pasar o sea
francamente yo quisiera saber qué es lo
que va a pasar no sé sin embargo lo que
sí digo es que se nos viene una época
muy compleja justamente por esa ausencia
de partidos políticos no hay partidos
políticos articulados hay una ausencia
de liderazgos que es que es algo
dramático en el caso ecuatoriano y
entonces claro lo que viene tenemos un
estado que nos entregó el gobierno
anterior absolutamente quebrado hemos
tenido un gobierno muy débil enfrentamos
la pandemia y ausencia de liderazgos no
es positivo el escenario entonces yo lo
que creo es que más bien lo que no tiene
una época muy dura para el país y lo que
nos quedan los ciudadanos y ciudadanas
es hacer un frente común de observar de
ejercer ciudadanía con mayor
responsabilidad para evitar que estos
populismos típicos de estos
clientelismos tan arraigados se sigan
expandiendo y que seguro mantienen la
pobreza es fruto de populismos perversos
así que eso no eso no lo cuestiona
muchísimas gracias pues a los tres
invitados les agradezco por haber
participado en este debate habernos
aclarado un poco este escenario político
que puede tener el ex presidente correa
'ecuador gracias a ustedes por su
sintonía por haber estado con nosotros
hoy tienen ya sobre la mesa los puntos
de vista de los invitados las
conclusiones las sacan ustedes en sus
hogares deje también sus comentarios y
todas sus preguntas a través de las
redes sociales siga con la programación
de france 24
[Música]